with us now to help us take the first
steps is Catherine price she is the
author of how to break up with your
phone the 30 day plan to take back your
life welcome first thing I want to do is
well it's a part of the process to
unplug
nobody can unplug it's like saying take
a diet and then stop eating forever yeah
so this is really about balance right
yeah and it's not it's not it wanna make
a point it's not a diet it's a gift to
yourself so it's about finding a balance
and finding a way of living that
actually gives you it's not it's not
about less time on your phone it's about
more time on your life basically one of
the things that was powerful to me and
learning about this over the years is
the physical reaction the need to reach
into your pocket which is more which is
quite powerful talk about that a little
yes the the reason that it makes you
twitchy not to have your phone is that
it's actually causing your brain to go
into this reward cycle similar to a slot
machine when you go to pull the slot
machine lover and then you want to keep
doing it compulsively that's exactly
what you're doing on your phone I mean
even to the degree of actually swiping
down to see what's gonna be waiting for
you and the fact that it's unpredictable
makes us want to do it even more you
have a 30-day challenge what's week one
all about week one is basically about
taking a step back assessing where you
are now and deciding where you want to
go so one thing that people do that
messes them up when they try to change
their relationship with their phone if
they jump into making these little
changes like turning it to grayscale
without having a broader vision of what
they want out of their relationship and
also what they want to spend their
newfound time on but you suggest
deleting social media apps why social
media apps are particularly pernicious
because they're designed to suck you in
and to keep you using them for as long
as possible so does that include
Instagram I'm so sorry yes because you
said listen it's not about throwing away
your phone it's about it's about your
relationship with your phone
exactly exactly week week - yeah once
you've kind of gotten your framework in
place week two is where you actually
start to make these concrete changes for
example getting a real alarm clock
instead of sleeping with your phone next
to your bed your phone's your alarm
clock you're going to touch it first
thing in the morning so it's really
about practical steps in a broader
context and the reward of all of this is
that you recapture something right and
that once you figure out what it is that
you want to recapture but you're also
recapturing a kind of
more Placid life you don't end the day
feeling shredded and and sin
yes our phones are really stressing us
out and if you take a break like you did
you will start to notice that are the
twitchiness fades which it will that you
actually start to feel a lot rejuvenated
and restored in a way that can be very
surprising you find out you were
stressed in ways you didn't even realize
that you were you do a digital detox and
you said it's a hangover that makes you
feel good yes after after you take a
break from your phone you will find
yourself wanting to check it less for a
few days afterwards and it is very
interesting to notice how good that
feels
week 3 week 3 is about what Michael Bain
was talking about retraining your
muscles of attention because our phones
are basically inhibiting our abilities
to focus form new memories concentrate
they're really undoing a lot of the hard
work we've put in over our lives to be
able to sustain attention so with things
like meditation and mindfulness those
are exercises that can help you regain
those abilities and then undo some of
those effects last is week 4 as quick as
you can
quick as you can it's an assessment of
what you've done so far and making a
plan to go forward to make your new
habit stick excellent how did it feel
John you didn't tell us that it was
tough but then at the end be having that
focus back was was nice and and
unexpected in certain ways and George
look good too oh thank you count
that's a dog look great